I'm sure most of you know and I don't
have to tell you that these are not
particularly bright days for the human
race and there are multi-level stories
here there's the the sort of full macro
of the world pandemic there's the micro
of how or how our individual lives are
being affected and then sort of in the
middle is how our specific country is
being led or or maybe more accurately
not led and lied to daily by the
president that we elected I mean not me
personally not many of you either but as
a country this person that we elected
and we're going to be looking through
all of these multi-level lenses and
perspectives today but I want to start
with what is increasingly the largest
and most destructive source of
disinformation around the virus which is
unfortunately Donald Trump himself
Donald Trump's press briefings which
we've been covering live and I hope that
you've been joining me for some of them
are riddled with lies and attacks on
journalists and are pushing out actual
doctors and scientists who are trying to
tell us the truth
trying to help the situation and instead
filled with Donald Trump telling lies
and insulting people and the number of
official cases in the United States is
exploding of course the more we test the
more cases we find because we've been so
behind on testing the number of deaths
is climbing every single day and we
can't even get straight answers about
have you sent ventilators to hospitals
how many have you sent masks to
hospitals from the stockpile you talk
about testing capacity coming online
every day you say by the end of the week
we will be here and then at the end of
the week we ask you and you say well
let's not really focus on the numbers we
are bringing on additional capacity and
over the weekend Donald Trump added
worse to worst by unleashing a
historically unhinged tweet storm
riddled with propaganda and signaling
that the White House is fully switching
from 50/50 propaganda and policy a
policy to deal with the virus to
exclusively propagandizing a
around this pandemic crisis so let's
look at some of the highlights and
because Donald Trump has almost nothing
on his schedule these days other than a
daily briefing usually one call with
governor's or one call with FEMA today I
looked at Trump's schedule this morning
all he has is a briefing at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern today and lunch with Mike Pence
that's it that's all that Donald Trump
is doing he has a lot of time to tweet
Trump tweeting a completely fact free
video from Fox News propagandist Jesse
Watters with the comment in all capital
letters Chinese virus fact check Trump
attacking governor's Trump attacking any
governor who says hey Trump might not be
doing enough here saying governor of
Illinois and a very small group of
certain other governors together with
fake news CNN and con cast calling
comcast comcast MC DNC shouldn't be
blaming the federal government for their
own shortcomings we are there to back
you up should you fail and always wid
will be in the midst of this Trump
retweeting about ten propaganda tweets
from Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell also riddled with
disinformation and lies and political
posturing rather than dealing with the
public health to call it a crisis seems
almost not strong enough Trump then
tweeting a thank you
to right-wing extremists channel Oh a n
one American news which has been tossing
softball questions at Donald Trump
during the coronavirus hearings saying
Thank You Jenn Falik RINO Oh a n for
throwing him a bogus question of course
about how everyone is just being so
unfair to him during the recent press
briefing now this next one I want to be
careful with because it actually
requires more analysis which we will do
later Trump tweeting about a possible
possible treatment for the virus saying
hydroxychloroquine and as if throw mice
and taken together have a real chance to
be one of the biggest game changers in
the history of medicine like that's
completely hyperbolic we're going to
talk about that as a possible treatment
but that's so hyperbolic Trump saying
the FDA has
move mountains thank you hopefully they
will both work hydroxychloroquine better
with azithromycin International Journal
of antimicrobial agents be put in use
immediately people are dying move fast
and god bless everyone we'll deal with
that in detail later so what we realized
as if we didn't know it from the last 38
months what we realized over the last
three days is we're in a real crisis now
this is not acting you know lying about
the deficit this is a real crisis we
don't have a leader we have a confused
70 year old man who has no idea what's
going on doesn't listen to medical
experts thinks he knows more and this is
not a game anymore now it already wasn't
the game when kids were in cages I
understand that it hasn't been a game
for a while now but there is a new
dimension in which this is no longer a
game Trump needs to step away from Kovac
let Anthony foutch e take over appoint
obama's ebola czar ronald claim as kovat
czar trump must be removed from the
presidency but if not that he has to be
distanced from the Cova da schoo and
this is one of the things I want to dig
into now I've been covering basically
every one of these coronavirus task
force press conferences live on YouTube
twitch Facebook and most recently
live-streaming on Twitter as well if
you've not been watching them your
mental state is probably much better
than that of people who have been
watching them because they really are
these propaganda explosions but I want
to highlight two moments that are just
complete microcosms absolutely the
epitome of what we're dealing with here
Donald Trump when asked specific
questions about numbers ventilators
masks how long this is all going to go
on when and how many tests are and will
be available Trump retreats to vague
generalities and weird statements and
Trump during one of the weekend press
conferences was asked about thermometer
availability are they available should
they be distributed should people be
buying thermometers and Trump instead
talked about just how stunning it is
that there are infrared thermometers not
a very new technology as you may know
which can take people's temperatures
from a few inches away this is what we
are dealing with
the person in charge right now is
surprised and stunned at infrared
thermometers this is from my stream over
the weekend so you'll you'll hear me
laughing which is what I do to avoid
crying because of what's going on I've
seen things when Toni mentions
thermometers they aim something at your
forehead they say this faraway bum and
they tell you what your temperature is I
said I've never seen that people Trump's
takeaway from all this is hey infrared
thermometers exist
this guy is operating on a totally
different level than anyone who has any
business dealing with this crisis and I
don't mean at a higher level I mean at a
lower level and during the same press
conference Trump was increasingly
tripped up about ventilators we have
about a hundred and seventy thousand
ventilators in the entire country now
somewhere between five and many more
times that a number of ventilators will
likely be needed during this pandemic
the US has ventilators in a strategic
stockpile Trump insists were getting
ventilators we're getting people
ventilators were getting more
ventilators we're sending them
everybody's going to have them never
tells us when never tells us how many
and Donald Trump here retreated to
expressing shock that hey did you know
ventilators are a machine not everybody
knows that take a look at this
horrifying and sad clip you know a
ventilator is a machine it's a very
complex machine and to think that we
have to order hundreds of thousands
nobody's ever heard of a thing like this
you know when we had in the stockpile we
had thousands in a stockpile of
thousands ready to go that's a lot all
of a sudden you need hundreds of
thousands and you're not talking about
you know the mask is whether it's
plastic or whether it's material that's
one thing but you're talking about a
very sophisticated computerized machine
and delicate wait a second all this time
ventilators are a machine now adding
insult to injury Donald Trump said it's
a very complicated machine only to have
Mike Pence show up a minute later and
say the opposite Mike Pence actually
said it's such a simple machine
not a complicated one that we're looking
at retrofitting other devices to make
ventilators take a look at this
it doesn't include what will be produced
as the president said we're seeing
companies step forward
well these manufacturers tell us that a
ventilator actually isn't a very
complicated piece of equipment and many
of them are literally surging forward to
create more ventilators os-- so it is a
very complicated and sophisticated piece
of equipment or it's not these are our
leaders right now not by choice
no Ebola czar and of course we are not
in good shape with these people in
charge there are so many levels of ugly
going on here this is just one of them
and it's it's truly depressing so I have
sadly just terrible news for you today
the United States trajectory of new
cases since we got our first hundred
cases is the worst in the world bar none
okay so look I'm gonna go through a few
bits of data with you today the way
things are going we are going to be in a
nightmarish dystopia that will make this
week and the hundreds of deaths this
week not seem that bad so before we look
at this I want to first update you on
the official numbers understand that
it's been an hour since I grabbed these
numbers so they've already changed
they've already gotten worse but as of
probably by the time you watch or listen
to this a few hours ago as of this
morning the United States had 68,000
official cases 68,000 official cases the
real number of cases of course is
probably between four and twenty times
that so we're looking at anywhere from
you know two hundred and seventy five
thousand cases 1.4 million cases we
really don't know because we aren't
testing we are we are backlogged on
testing and a lot of people aren't being
tested at all so we just don't know but
the official case number there it is in
terms of the states
New York currently has just under half
of the whole country's cases other
hotspots are New Jersey California is
seeing a big increase Washington State
has had a lot of cases they are getting
it under control there
spiked earlier in Washington as many of
you know and then you've got a bunch of
states right around 2000 official cases
Michigan Florida Illinois Massachusetts
Louisiana and then you've got another
tier in Georgia Texas Pennsylvania
Colorado at every state has some cases
at this point now of course the United
States is a different sized country than
others were a large country
geographically we're also a large
country in terms of population we've got
about 340 million people here with
enough land area here you essentially
have states that both in geographical
size and in population can be bigger
than many individual European countries
so what we need to be looking at just
the case numbers don't tell us that much
we need to look at the trajectory how
quickly our cases and deaths increasing
in the United States when we look at
that rate when we look at how we are
tracking one thing that we look at is
after we got our first hundred cases
meaning once you get a hundred cases is
when you know this is going to be an
issue and you've got to start doing
stuff we look at after a hundred cases
have been reached how quickly have the
numbers gone up on this chart that we're
putting up for you which I will describe
a steeper curve means a faster increase
in cases so when you look I've
highlighted certain lines to make this
easier to read cases in the United
States have increased more quickly than
they did in Spain and more quickly than
they did in Italy Italy is one of the
most disastrous and tragic situations
around the world our cases are
increasing more quickly than that and
since about day 19 after hitting 100
cases we even passed China's level of
increase which initially had absolutely
cartoonishly disastrous numbers so the
point is we started later in that other
country started seeing case growth
sooner than the United States in
absolute terms in February instead of in
March but in terms of the speed at which
cases are increasing here in the United
States we are doing worse than just
about every country and the implications
are disastrous if this doesn't change
and
number 30 states aren't doing a damn
thing to make it slow down in another 10
days we are going to have an
unconscionable number of cases an insane
number of people hospitalized the
medical system will be overwhelmed
deaths are going to skyrocket and
hospitals are actually already
overwhelmed some of the stuff Trump is
talking about you know ad hoc FEMA
facilities bringing a hospital ship up
to New York City it takes weeks or
longer to get that stuff online so right
now while we're working on a vaccine
that's a year away we're testing large
clinical trials looking at anywhere from
four to there's really thirty or forty
different possible treatments that are
being explored the only tool we have
right now is physical distancing and
staying the hell home and Donald Trump
is starting to talk about ending it on
April 12th and filling churches in large
parts of the country so just do the math
as to whether this makes sense meanwhile
Germany while dealing with lots of cases
they are keeping their death rate very
very low and when this started and the
death rate was low in Germany we thought
well Germany just hasn't gotten that
many cases yeah the the more serious
cases are going to develop the death
rate is going to go up Germany now has
nearly 40,000 confirmed cases and only
222 deaths as of this morning still
tragic 222 deaths but it's a death rate
of about half of 1% that's very good
compared to what we're seeing in a lot
of other countries the question is why
one thing is their medical system is not
yet overwhelmed number two they started
testing earlier so they have probably a
closer to accurate assessment of the
number of cases still not totally
accurate but closer than the United
States we know and dr. Isaac BOE gosh
told us earlier this week the outcomes
are much better when the system is not
overwhelmed the earlier and the more
that you test so you can quarantine
people the better your going to do in
terms of preventing that medical system
from becoming overwhelmed overwhelmed
this is the point of social distancing
this is the point of flattening the
curve given 100,000 cases in a month
versus 100,000 cases in six months
prefer it in six months because it keeps
the hospitals less full and therefore
the outcomes are better meanwhile we
have a president who wants to go in the
other direction and let her rip on April
12th I'm getting now dozens of emails
daily from people in the Netherlands
saying we're fully shut down until I
think they said June 1 Canada saying we
you know even our briefings from Trudeau
he's by himself versus Trump still
talking about social distancing and up
on a dais with a crowd of people in a
room full of reporters people are
emailing me saying I'm so sorry David
that you're dealing with a country that
is doing seemingly the opposite of what
many other countries have figured out
it's it's very very bad let's take a
quick break after the break we will talk
about who do Americans trust when it
comes to the virus you might be
surprised or maybe not we'll also talk
about 5g conspiracy theories exploding
now that they can be interlinked with
coronavirus those stories and more
coming up right after the break okay I
hate that we have to do this but the
amount of disinformation and lies about
the virus coming from our own president
is spreading virally so it's not just
the virus that's spreading virally the
lies are spreading virally as well we
are going to go on a tour now not of the
lies that Donald Trump is told during
his presidency that numbers about 16,000
it would take us months to go through
them we were going to go on a tour of
lies not from the entire coronavirus
crisis because that would take weeks
we're just doing a partial tour of the
lies that Donald Trump has told and
spread just during the last few days
about coronavirus look at the havoc that
this man is wreaking first Donald Trump
insisted that he did everything right
away and correctly when it comes to the
defense production Act this is a
mechanism that harkens back to 1950 in
the Korean War
i misstated yesterday that this was a
world war ii era thing it's a Korean War
era thing from 1950 the idea is that in
a time of a national emergency war
pandemic whatever the government can
essentially force industry to produce
things that are needed for the war or
the pandemic Trump in
Bouck the act supposedly but didn't
enforce it or use it saying it's a tool
that's ready if I need it but I don't
actually need it
now we need ventilators we need masks
urgently this has been a completely
incoherent explanation from Donald Trump
and the New York Times appears to have
figured out the conundrum Trump has been
lobbied successfully by the United
States Chamber of Commerce not to
actually use the defense production act
because they don't like it so Trump has
been twisting himself into a pretzel the
last two or three briefings to say this
incoherent thing of well I invoked it
but I haven't used it it's ready and I'm
doing everything right and it's a lie
and it appears to be because industry
successfully lobbied him not to use it
number two Trump continues to hype
chloroquine and azithromycin as a
possible game-changer something he
thinks will be the cure for coronavirus
we've already gone over this in detail
it's not a game changer it's a possible
thing side-effects are a big issue
reports of heart and vision issues are
starting to come in and once again the
Surgeon General had to go on Fox News
where trumps this information spreads
quickly and say no the this and we're
gonna look at this this is right after
Fox and Friends had dr. oz on spreading
more of it here is Surgeon General
Jerome Adams explaining that this is not
a cure this is not what Trump is
claiming this this to be you know doctor
we had dr. oz on at the top of this hour
and what he talked about was how
promising he thinks that malaria drug
when used in concert with z-pak was with
one of the French doctors who treated 36
people and their viral level all went
from a hundred down to zero after just
five or six days he said his biggest
problem right now and he's starting his
own clinical trials at Columbia and he
mentioned the Cleveland Clinic I think
is gonna do the same thing he wonders
you know and worries about the fact that
we don't have enough pills yet in this
country if that works
here's the thing about those drugs
there's may and there's and there's
actually does and so these may be
promising and so we're trying to make
them as available as possible to people
across the country we need to verify
through studies that they actually work
but I also again want to go back to the
fact that we are it's not practical to
think we're going to treat our way out
of this problem with new drugs or with
ventilators or with supplies we need to
lower demand we need more people talking
about staying at home it's why I reached
out to Kylie Jenner last week it's why
my kids say dad reach out to Lauren gray
and Roman Atwood and have them help
these Millennials understand they're
spreading virus and the more they spread
the more we're going to need these drugs
the more we're gonna need ventilators
and masks so there's an actual doctor
trying to push back against Trump's
hyperbole and distortion because he is
being deceptive he is spreading
disinformation and it already led to one
death I'll tell you about that later
continuing our truer our tour of Donald
Trump's coronavirus lies of just the
last few days Trump is starting to tweet
he did it Sunday night he did it Monday
night he did it this morning he's
starting to tweet that maybe we're gonna
wrap up the social distancing the
physical distancing this is very
dangerous and meanwhile state governors
who are dealing with this in a more real
way are putting in place shelter and
place orders we just got one yesterday
here in Massachusetts and other states
are getting them as well but meanwhile
Donald Trump is spreading flat-out
dangerous speculation by tweeting Sunday
night that quote we cannot let the Cure
be worse than the problem itself at the
end of the 15 day period we will make a
decision as to which way we want to go
Trump again tweeting this morning we are
going to get people back to work but
we're gonna take care of older folks
Trump's economic adviser Larry Kudlow
also starting to parrot this saying we
don't want the Cure to be worse than the
disease and this is extremely dangerous
number one there's no way in hell that
all we need is another seven days number
two you have people who are desperate to
start going out and do whatever they
want which I can understand I mean I
want to do it also but we can't give
people
any cover under which to do it and Trump
is lying here and he shouldn't be saying
this and then lastly one of the reasons
Trump claims that he doesn't need to
enforce the defense production Act is
that GM and Ford are already making
ventilators and everything's great this
is just a lie
no automaker is anywhere near ready to
make ventilators GM General Motors
reportedly says they have a plan for
starting to obtain most but not all of
the parts they would need to be able to
begin the manufacturer of ventilators at
some point in the future it will
realistically take months for them to
even actually start churning out
ventilators they also don't need Trump's
permission to do it which Trump hasn't
been saying but with my permission GM is
doing this it is lie after lie after lie
and it's going to get much much worse
one of the things about Donald Trump is
that the more difficult things get the
more likely he is to lie uncontrollably
and this is getting more and more
difficult the death toll is climbing
here in the US you should expect the
lies to continue my hope is that our
state governors can help fight this
because Trump's causing problems the
state governors that are taking this
seriously
Cuomo Newsom Baker others I know I'm
missing a lot of people he doesn't
understand anything about medicine or
the virus and the governors are having
to basically work against Trump in favor
of sanity and reason people around Trump
keep explaining this stuff yesterday
during the press conference Trump
started asking dr. Burks questions that
made it clear he barely knows anything
about a symptomatic contagion or any of
this stuff he doesn't get pandemics he
doesn't understand morality and there
are this is a very bad time for this
degree of weaponized ignorant
incompetence and delusions of grandeur
and we may very quickly get into this
battle between Trump saying get back to
work and governors and probably Airlines
and others saying no no we're not we're
not doing it and that may happen sooner
than later
okay so let's now continue digging into
the Easter thing
slowly but surely we've learned that
Donald Trump wants to let her rip very
very soon
and get the country open back up he
wants to do it on Easter
now the absurdity of talking about
opening up a country where 30 states
have not closed anything down is
ludicrous and incredibly dangerous I'm
getting emails from people in Amsterdam
where there are some provisions in place
until June 1 in the Netherlands hearing
from people in Italy Spain so many
places they are horrified by what Donald
Trump now wants to do so they want to
open it back up before 30 states have
even done anything but they also are
talking about opening it back up when
the death toll is exploding it's growing
exponentially we have case numbers
growing like crazy and of course the
more we test the more cases we will find
because we've been under testing but
Donald Trump is being very clear now he
wants churches packed by Easter Sunday
April 12 so look at the evolution of
this Sunday night Trump tweets we can't
have the Cure be worse than the disease
we've already covered that with you
Monday he tweets people want to work and
we've got to get him back to work showed
you that tweet earlier Tuesday Fox News
townhall Trump floats for the first time
I'm looking at Easter April 12th and
then after yesterday's Town Hall on Fox
News Trump was interviewed also on Fox
News by Bill Hemmer and he said I want
churches packed on Easter here's the
video and you'll notice also Trump has
adopted a new voice which I call Corona
voice it's a very unusual delivery which
he uses when talking about coronavirus
related stuff that makes no sense
usually he uses a voice that I think he
thinks sounds empathetic it sounds very
very fake but when he's delivering news
that that equates to people are gonna
die
Trump has adopted what I call Corona
voice take a look take a listen you're a
Town Hall today you threw out a date
where you think America can be working
again and that's Easter Sunday that's
nineteen days
how did you come up well it's 19 days
but add another 7 because we've been
doing this now for 7 so that's from the
time we heard about 1700 time well yes
around the time we closed it up so you
can add 7 tonight
look Easter is a very special day for me
and I see it's sort of in that time line
that I'm thinking about and I say
wouldn't it be great to have all of the
churches full you know the churches
aren't allowed essentially to have much
of a congregation there and most of them
I watched on Sunday online and he was
terrific by the way but order line is
never going to be like being there so I
think Easter Sunday and you'll have
packed churches all over our country I
think would be a beautiful time and it's
just about the time line that I think is
right it gives us more chance to work on
what we're doing and I'm not sure that's
going to be the day but I would love to
aim it right at Easter Sunday so we're
open for church service and services
generally on Easter Sunday that would be
a beautiful thing my instinct is that if
indeed churches are packed on Easter
it'll be funerals not for Easter service
and I asked yesterday on my Twitter
account
is there any metric or data point that
anyone can point me to that indicates
Trump is right that we've turned the
corner and are now on the tail end of
the as he calls it war against the
invisible scourge or scourge as he has
referred to it I was hoping someone
would point me to something like even
even if it's a weak case for having
turned the corner I was hoping someone
would respond to me on Twitter and say
look at these numbers look at those
numbers we have turned the corner but
nobody could and I looked at the numbers
again this morning cases are rising
every day the death toll is exploding
every day we have more new cases than
the day before yesterday we had 11,000
new confirmed cases which probably means
somewhere between four and ten times
that in actual cases because we're
really only testing symptomatic people
unless you're rich or famous the death
toll is exploding more death every day
deaths nearly doubling from Monday to
Tuesday
monday we had 141 deaths Tuesday we had
225 there is no responsible metric by
which we are even remotely ready to talk
about packing churches on Easter and
again if I said this before
if Trump said listen I really want to
open up some parts of the country to
younger people on Easter not older folks
not the hot spots we got to get some
young people back to work I would say if
you want a shot at that you need every
governor all 50 governor's to shut it
down from today until April 12 work with
me
Trump should say in all 50 states stay
home stay home order shut down
non-essential businesses you know take
out only at restaurants spacing people
out of grocery stores all that stuff
that's what I need you to do to give me
a shot at giving you some good news on
April 12th it would still be very risky
but it might be defensible in some way
Trump saying with 30 states still doing
nothing
I want churches packed on Easter is as
insane as it is dangerous as it is
irresponsible and this is the
calculation that they've made and what
it seems to me is going on is that they
are all skipping all of the headlines
that will happen for weeks and months if
they do this of the death toll exploding
of people dying at unprecedented rates
and that they'll just see the stock
market going up and they'll see an
unemployment number that's not as bad as
it otherwise would be
they'll see a GDP decline that's not as
bad as it otherwise would be
and they're envisioning getting to the
other side of this scot-free and being
able to claim some kind of heroic
victory I don't know maybe he's right I
mean as tragic as it will be is it true
that many people in the country would
accept a higher death toll to feel as
though the economy is doing better and
people are working like maybe my
perspective is wrong and when you look
at the approval polls of Trump which
we'll talk about on the bonus show today
his approval rating is higher than it's
been in a long time
more than half the country believes
Trump is doing a good job handling
that's like maybe I'm the odd man out
I the one who says Who am I the one who
is the outlier by saying this doesn't
make sense the economic a situation that
would eventually recover anyway is not
worth killing so many additional people
maybe I'm the crazy person let me know
we're covering this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show while you're
there if you want to see my behind the
scenes video of my home studio setup
that's on my personal Instagram David
Pakman quick break right back after this
so I've noted this a few times already
if we are going to deal with the current
pandemic in a way that would even come
close to being called successful and
again now when we talk about success
we're talking about how much can we
limit the number of people who die
because the number is climbing rapidly
and it's a it's it's a question of
limiting that number sadly if we're
going to deal with it in anything that
would approximate a success it's going
to likely depend on our state governors
it's not going to happen
because Donald Trump's a direction gives
some kind of unified and and wealth well
appointed well crafted strategy and in
fact we're seeing Donald Trump
increasingly push in the other direction
it's becoming very much obvious that
Donald Trump is all but completely
committed to reopening the country
letting it rip as dr. Anthony Fauci sort
of characterized it on Easter Sunday
April 12th now it's still possible that
the numbers will be so ugly by that
point and we'll look at the numbers
later and it seems to be going in that
direction it's possible that the numbers
will be so ugly that Donald Trump will
be talked out of it even by people as
incompetent as Jared Kushner who
apparently has a hand in everything he's
supposedly going to be not not only is
he gonna fix the israeli-palestinian
conflict Jared Kushner is expected I
guess to deal with coronavirus as well
despite having no experience whatsoever
in infectious disease and we've been
thinking about how different state
governors are likely to react to Donald
Trump wanting to let it rip on April
12th because remember still now at
nearly the end of March more than half
of state governors have done
nothing yet as of two days ago 30 of 50
states had no state-level directives
about shutting down non-essential
businesses self-isolation staying home
schools etc now many of those states had
individual cities that may have made
such determinations but 30 of 50 that's
60 percent right that's three-fifths
weren't even doing anything yet
imagine the insanity of talking about
let's open it back up when 30 states
haven't yet even closed anything down
it's completely crazy so when they talk
about April 12th understand that many
states nothing's changed those states
are just standing by and his business as
usual which makes this all the more
absurd there we gonna reopen from never
having closed but the most important
thing here is if there is anything
positive and we're desperately looking
for silver linings everyday and there
aren't many it does seem that more and
more governors are just not going to
follow Donald Trump's direction they are
going to say no to Donald Trump and
they're going to do what's right for
their state which is likely to stay shut
down for what is unfortunately a
relatively long period of time we've got
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo clearly
not on the same page as Donald Trump and
talking about more closures more
limitations as we get into April and
eventually going going into May
California governor Gavin Newsom he's
very clearly operating under a
completely different sort of set of
facts based on the last thing he said
the extension of stay-at-home orders in
California it's going to go for a while
even in Texas where lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick has been completely unhinged
and talking about sacrificing
grandparents in order to save the stock
market for further grandchildren you
even have the governor there Texas
Republican governor Greg Abbott who's
pretty bad he now is at least endorsing
the stay at home orders that individual
cities in Texas have put in place I know
it's not that much they're doing it
anyway it doesn't change anything that
Greg Abbott endorses it but it is a good
sign and then you've got Arizona
Governor Doug Ducey who says public
health must
before the economy yeah that's true
South Dakota governor Kristi Noem says
business activity must be limited not
relaxed at this time and in many ways
this is going to become and it is a
story already about states rights versus
the federal government which is an issue
that it's an issue that is a common
political debate but I'd certainly
didn't expect on day one of this fiasco
that one of the greatest determinants as
to how this goes was going to be the
issue of states rights versus the
federal government and it probably
wouldn't be the issue if we had
competent science-based leadership
coming from the oval office rather than
dr. stand on stage but they basically
shut their mouths while Donald Trump
brags about this that and the other
thing that he claims he did while
sometimes during these press briefings
not even talking about the case numbers
or the death toll it's very difficult to
imagine now thinking about Massachusetts
I don't see Republican Massachusetts
governor Charlie Baker and a lot of
other governors jumping onboard with
April 12 especially when we are hearing
about more school closures more business
closures extending the school closures
here in Massachusetts and in other
places and especially when you look at
the numbers which we will look at later
I hope that governors will will maintain
sanity now interestingly enough the
governor of Mississippi Tate Reeves he's
going crazy to stop abortions during the
corona virus pandemic but he's very much
welcome welcoming the idea of a wide
open on April 12th we know of course
that Mississippi's health system is a
disaster we know that the underlying
health conditions impact coronavirus
mortality rates drastically it could
very quickly get very very ugly in
Mississippi for Tate Reeves well we'll
be watching that and then there are even
discussions starting about the
possibility of States actually putting
in checkpoints at their own borders
imagine for example that you have
certain states that are all in with
we've got a distance whereas other
states are all about let it rip you
could conceivably have state governors
wanting to set up checkpoints
at their borders which is a very
complicated legal thing to do in the
United States freedom of movement
between states is determined by what's
called the privileges and immunities
clause of the Constitution and it is a
pretty significant restriction on states
being able to erect barriers or block
entry to states free movement between
states is in the Constitution it's very
difficult to do that if it gets to that
point
imagine that Louisiana takes it
seriously but you know Alabama doesn't
or whatever you could very quickly see
that hypothetical conflict become a very
real legal conflict in some of these
states last thing I want to come back to
you here from the beginning right-wing
media choosing to entertain Donald
Trump's completely delusional
perspective on all of this has done such
drastic and permanent damage it has led
to nearly half the country or more than
half the country by States maybe not by
population to essentially believe that
this is no big deal that it is going to
kind of just take care of itself we
don't have to do anything that is a
belief that will increase the death toll
the death toll is already higher than it
otherwise would be if every state back
in whatever the date was March 15th or
so where more and more states started
taking this seriously and had said we're
gonna shut the whole thing down now
Donald Trump seems increasingly
indifferent to the death toll he instead
during his press conference talks about
stock market how much money he's gonna
give businesses how quickly he can get
businesses reopened no mention sometimes
of the death toll even if testing
there's barely mentioning sometimes
until Donald Trump now got his hands on
this talking point if we've tested more
people in eight days than South Korea
did in the previous eight weeks or
something of course ignoring the fact
that we're a far larger country with
many more people we're in real trouble
here and I'm hoping because we're
desperate for some kind of silver lining
I'm hoping governor's will help except
they've got to all get on the same page
and right now they are not twenty
governors doing something thirty
governors doing nothing we have a
coronavirus stimulus deal that has
finally been reached and as some
you might have heard on my live streams
everyday there's like three proposals
floated and maybe it's going to happen
maybe it's not and then it gets canceled
or replaced with something else so
because we've all along if I had talked
about every possible deal the entire
show would have been just possible deals
that didn't become a reality we just
decided we're going to wait and then
we'll discuss the deal once it's
actually done the priorities for me are
we've got to bail people out people with
bills people with expenses people who
need money and may no longer have a job
we've got to do something about small
business very very important because a
lot of small businesses can't weather
this I'm talking to small business
owners all the time in my neighborhood
and other neighborhoods in Boston who
say you know I can make thirty percent
of what I was making before but the
problem is my rent is forty percent so I
need something I need some kind of
bridge to get me there and you want to
provide capital strategically to reduce
interruptions of different kinds prevent
the unemployment rate from exploding as
much as it would without some incentive
for small businesses to keep people on
etc this is the largest stimulus package
in American history now a stimulus
package the concept of a stimulus
package is it's a Keynesian idea the
idea being government spending can
lessen the severity of a recession
stimulate the economy boost employment
boost spending that's the framework it's
a Keynesian framework we're talking
about this deal was reached just hours
ago around 1:30 a.m. Eastern Time very
early this morning here is Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
announcing it at last we have a deal
after days of intense discussions the
Senate has reached a bipartisan
agreement on a historic relief package
for this pandemic it will rush new
resources onto the front lines of our
nation's healthcare fight and it will
inject trillions of dollars of cash into
the economy as fast as possible as you
can tell there Mitch McConnell just
overwhelmed with emotion over this
historic deal so what's in it some of
the details are still being worked out
some of the language is still being
written as of as of this second but
what we have so far it'll be a two
trillion dollar stimulus package people
individuals earning up to $75,000 in
income will get a $1200 one-time check
couples double the money for double the
income limit $2,400 if as a couple you
earn up to a hundred and fifty thousand
you get an additional five hundred
dollars per child based on what we saw
an hour ago against some of the final
details may change the $1,200 check
starts to phase out as you approach
ninety nine thousand dollars in income
as an individual or a hundred
ninety-eight thousand as a couple and
once you get to that level 99 K per
person you lose the twelve you lose all
the money unit you get zero after that
point unemployment insurance will be
expanded to include people that are
furloughed gig workers freelancers right
people that would not normally qualify
for unemployment insurance they will
also be adding and this is one of the
things that's a probably but we don't
know for sure yet it looks like they're
going to increase the unemployment
payments by six hundred bucks a week for
four months above the state base
different states unemployment insurance
is state-based so the benefit in
Massachusetts may be different from the
benefit in Florida or in California
that'll be up to buy six hundred bucks a
week by the federal government there
will be an employee retention tax credit
for businesses to keep people on so
we've seen two versions between 25 and
50 billion dollars for passenger
airlines between 4 and 8 billion for
cargo airlines 17 billion for companies
determined to be important to national
security the details of course still
remain to be determined they're roughly
five hundred billion dollars in a
corporate liquidity program these would
be loans to businesses through banks
very important to understand that would
be through banks and then another three
hundred sixty seven billion roughly
through a small business loan program
through the small business it's
Association thirty billion in education
funding twenty five billion in transit
funding so this is the bulk of it now
there's a question about the the income
limit on the twelve hundred dollar check
five K what's the process and
verification of that if it's based on
2019 income a lot of people haven't
filed their 2019 tax returns so what
happens there we don't know there's the
idea that you would use 2018 income if
you've not yet filed your 2019 tax
return excuse me could that be gamed in
some way we don't know but this is part
of the the detail that still needs to be
worked out another question is how does
this impact self-employed people there
are some other specifics that need to be
sorted out but it's finally happening
it's happening far too late
it's happening after a lot of personal
financial damage has already happened to
people who have been laid off for one
week two weeks even longer in some cases
truck Schumer Senate Minority Leader
says that trumps businesses will not be
eligible for any of this stuff that's an
assertion from chuck schumer i've not
yet seen any language that makes that
clear this is the framework we have so
far in the background of all this donald
trump increase increasingly wants to
reopen everything or close to everything
on Easter Sunday April 12th I want to
talk about that next and we'll be doing
a sort of deeper dive into that a little
bit later in the program